well I think the government's going to
be looking to increase spending by less
than was previously planned
and they uh May well announce some tax
increases but I think they need to be
careful about this because the main
instrument that we have
to curb inflation is the interest rate
and that's with the bank of England the
bank of England is going to have to
raise interest rates further
um Jeremy Hunt needs to make sure that
he's not tightening too much
with his public spending and tax
announcements when he makes them
tomorrow
okay 11.1 though that is alarming
um 41 year high yes it's a very high
rate of inflation it's five and a half
times the two percent Target that the
bank is Meant to hit
um now the increase uh this month
um is mainly driven by food and energy
prices the rise from 10.1 to 11.1 if you
take those out
inflation
um is still very high it will be 6.5
without food and energy price inflation
and I think that's going to be the big
concern for the bank of England that is
not just to do with food and energy
prices it's not just to do with the war
in Ukraine uh there's more generalized
problem with inflation in the economy
for example Furniture prices going up by
about 10 restaurants and hotels uh
components in the Consumer Price Index
going up by about 10
so there's a more generalized problem of
inflation which the bank of England
needs to get on top of both England had
been predicting 13 though hadn't they in
some instances although we're hearing
from Paul at the top of the show when
these figures first dropped and he was
suggesting that this is probably as high
as it's going to go
well the bank of England forecast uh
that in the last three months of this
year
um and October which we've just had the
figures for is one of those months
inflation is going to average about 10.9
so just below 11 now it's gone above 11
but I would be wary about saying this is
as bad as it gets
um because the bank's forecast doesn't
really suggest that inflation is going
to come down
um significantly until the middle of
next year so I think we're in for a few
more shocks perhaps on the inflation
front over the winter and why does that
leave our viewers at home who are
watching this and thinking 11.1 I can
never remember it being that high
no well um it is hard to remember
because it wasn't that High
um it hasn't been that high since the
early 1980s
and there may be some people who are
saying I wasn't even born then and some
people have just got on the housing
ladder and are going to see their
interest rates go up quite significantly
they're going to be quite concerned
there is obviously going to be a squeeze
on the economy
um because of higher interest rates and
that's where why Jeremy Hunt needs to be
careful of not making that squeeze too
intense options does he have well I
think his options are
to ask departments to Reign back on
public spending but there's some very
big areas of public spending that the
government really can't uh economize on
like health and education I mean the
government spends money on things
because they're of benefit to us and
therefore it's going to be in my view a
long haul in terms of getting public
finances properly under control
rather than just something that he's
going to need to do for a year or two
there needs to be a long-term plan
that's announced tomorrow and he needs
to take account of the fact that if he
squeezes too hard if he goes too hard in
cutting spending or raising taxes he may
actually make the problem of the economy
worse
perhaps not as bad as the disastrous
coupling of truss and quoting and their
mini budget at the end of September
we've been told recently that that's
cost 30 odd billion pounds to the UK
economy what does that money go
well I think some of it is to do with
higher interest payments that the
government has to make
some of it is a range of other things
that were caused by all the volatility
um that that budget Unleashed
but I think that highlights the fact
that that
um that that budget went in the opposite
direction it was it was cutting taxes it
was um spending extra money
um
if you do too big a Lurch with
government spending and tax then you can
create unpredictable economic
consequences so Jeremy Hunt's got a bit
of a balancing act to do
to do enough to show that he's getting
public finances under control
but not to destabilize the economy by
tightening too much in the short term
can the 11.1 percent inflation the
highest in 41 years as you said can that
be good news for anybody
um I don't think inflation is good news
um
it's a there's a good reason why we have
Bank of England tasked with trying to
keep inflation uh at around about two
percent which is sufficiently low that
nobody would really notice it
um I was thinking particularly about
Savers interest rates going up as a
result of inflation and well it should
be Savers well there is some
um upside from higher interest rates for
people who are trying to save
um and want to rely on interest income
and actually to some extent we're
redressing the balance from a long
period where interest rates uh were too
low in my opinion
and where
um Savers therefore were disadvantaged
now borrowers are going to to experience
increased costs but as you say Savers
are likely to benefit uh from from
higher interest rates but the question
is really getting the right level of
interest rates for the economy and the
priority at the moment for the bank of
England is going to be to raise interest
rates to a level where it actually
begins to control inflation and bring it
down let's see what happens after
tomorrow's Autumn statement it's good to
talk to you Mr sentence thanks for
coming in to see us thanks